hier soir M6 diffusé un nouveau numéro
de L'Amour est dans le pré on va
débriefer l'émission avec un invité ce
soir on va être avec Jean-Michel vous
rappelez de Jean-Michel ah oui bien sûr
il est bah il est là il est
là Jean-Michel de la saison 6 de
l'émission Jean-Michel je l'adore en
plus Jean-Michel clavau c'est un des mes
préférés euh il avait participé à la
saison 6 en 2011 il avait deux
prétendantes Nathalie Alexandra et au
moment de leur annoncer son choix il
avait fait vraiment le bonhomme CIT un
petit peu le le le le Robert De Niro de
l'amour est dans le Prix
regardez bonsoir bonsoir vous être
rissance
merci donc ce qu'on va faire j'ai pris
une décision donc vous avez passé chacun
votre tour je vais commencer par toi
Alexandra hm hm donc tu vas monter dans
ta chambre s'il te plaît natthalie
d'accord et s'il te plaît quand
Alexandra va mon dans sa chambre je veux
pas que vous voyez pourquoi parce que
c'est comme ça
Jean-Michel Jean-Michel qui est avec
nous et merci d'être là Jean-Michel je
suis très heureux de te voir de rien
également et je vis dire j'embrasse tous
les agriculteurs qui sont voilà que à
chaque fois que j'ai reçu des
agriculteurs sur le plateau voilà j'ai
trouvé que c'était des gens formidables
et comme je disais voilà il y a des
métiers très importants parler hein des
professeurs voilà des hôpitaux et les
agriculteurs font partie des métiers les
plus importants en France et on les aime
nos agriculteurs il faut les protéger
parce qu'ils sont souvent dans la galère
et on fait pas assez pour eux et je le
redis encore ce soir parce qu'on parle
de l'amour et dans le prè je le redirai
d'ailleurs chaque fois qu'on le fait je
vous dis il faut aider les agriculteurs
parce que je trouve que le gouvernement
vous êtes pas assez voilà je c'est pas
facile merci d'être là Jean-Michel alors
vous aviez choisi natthalie à l'époque
et pour la convaincre de votre amour
vous aviez fait un un move de drague
plutôt
originale je va te faire écouter une
chanson oui tu vas l'écouter mais un
conseil s'il te plaît pleure pas parce
que je obligé de
[Musique]
t'accompagner je l'entend je l' prends
mais j'ai plus envie d'y croire je les
apprends comme un enfant mais je ne veux
plus les
voir c'est
[Musique]
joli bravo Jean-Michel alors
Jean-Michel je veux pas que tu nous
dises où tu en est tu nous le diras
après parce que je veux en savoir plus
sur toi tu nous direas après parce que
on va faire déjà le débrief de l'épisode
d'hier tu regardes toujours sur la m
dans le prê ouais non non pas du tout
non ça fait depu chier non ça me fait
pas chier c'est que je trouve que c'est
plus comme avant ah ouais bah ça tu vas
nous en parler pourquoi qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui a changé ben je trouve
qu'il faut voir les grosses fermes il
faut voir que les agriculteurs gagnent
bien leur vie c'est pas vrai ouais c'est
ça donc voilà je trouve ça c'est dommage
ais toi tu trouvais que c'était mieux
avant ou il montrait vraiment VO mieux
avant il faisait voir les petites fer
voilà les agriculteurs étaient en
difficulté donc aujourd'hui c'est
intéressant ce que tu dis là parce que
tu dis que maintenant il y a que des
grosses fermes dans dans la le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on veut faire des
usines ouais c'est ça
ouais donc je trouve ça dommage ouais tu
tu es pas content j'ai l'impression bah
on a pas le choix ouais mais bon alors
il y avait un couple hier que c'est
Charles et Véronique dans l'épisode
d'hier il est parti la retrouver chez
elle il a l'air très content de la
revoir mais lui le romantisme c'est pas
son truc regardez et séparé de ses plus
belles claquettes chaussettes que notre
véau à cour vers l'élu de son
cœur
oh
je suis très très très contente qu'on se
revoir Ahou ça c'est la douche oui on va
se CER
la machine à V ça vibre
[Musique]
oua
enfin arrê et ver qui cherche le levier
de vitesse non mais on peut pas les
tenir ces
deuxl ouis hier Laour dans le prê ah
ouais c'est vrai que alors malgré la
bonne ambiance et les po po de camion
Charles a fait une blague qui n'a pas
vraiment plu à Vero qui est hyper
jalouse et on a même cru que c'était la
fin de l'aventure pour eux heureusement
tout s bien terminé regardez jolie
serveuse et Charles comme bon nombre de
garçons a les yeux qui traînent elle est
bien
jolie oh ça y est oh ça y est oh
oh je suis resté bloqué là-dessus et
puis après B que ça plaît ça plaît pas
bah c'est la preuve que que je tiens à
toi je serais pas jalouse he je vais pas
te quitter comme ça c'est pas parce que
je parle comme ça que j'ai parlé comme
ça t'inquiète
[Musique]
pas je te laisserai
pas mais qu'est-ce qu'il a Dani car lui
parce que il a juste fait un petit
compliment
elle est bien jolie c'est plus qu'un
quoi vous êtes avec votre femme vous
regarder une seruse elle est bien jolie
fin en même temps là qu'estce tu penses
toi je pense la même chose que vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quoi
il il a dit je pense la même chose que
vous j'ai rien dit moi non non mais bon
après voilà après voilà c'est c'est bon
et toi toi tu en es où toi ah
aujourd'hui ça va je suis un homme
heureux ma vie va très bien j'étais
voilà j'ai eu j'ai eu des gros problèmes
dans les problèmes financiers tout ça
j'étais j'étais descendu au plus bas
donc je pouvais que remonter et
aujourd'hui j'ai bien remonté la p
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé bah j'ai voulu
me suicider parce que moi j'ai perdu ma
ferme et je brouillais du noir donc je
me renfermais et puis euh la suite après
la MO dans le pressin après oui parce
que j'ai perdu ma ferme et donc ma ferme
voilà mes vaches c'était tout pour moi
donc tu fais quoi aujourd'hui jemich
aujourd'hui je le droit de cité je
travaille pour le groupe Vinc je suis
entretien les abords d'accord et puis je
suis heureux comme ça maintenant je j'ai
acheté une maison ça fait 3 ans ou là
ouais donc le lundi je signé mon CDI et
le vendredi je signé le compromis pour
acheter ma maison
bien donc puis là du coup mois de mai
j'ai créé ma propre maison édition ouais
je sais j'ai vu tu tu as des livres un H
Liv voilà un homme heureux c'est mon
dernier livre les animaux ne montent pas
et pas je suis
d'accord et je verse un Arou pour les
Chen guides et mon un homme heureux je
l'ai écrit avec mon ami Alexis Alexis
char on s'est rencontré dans une
dédicace et puis on a décidé de faire un
lit ensemble et tu en es où
sentimentalement aujourd'hui je suis
célibataire puis pour le moment je suis
bien comme ça ouais tu es tranquille de
va ça fait combien de temps que tu tu as
pas de de meuf ça fait à peu près 3 mois
3 mois ça
[Applaudissements]
il a tré le
biscuit il trompé c'est V il apé son
c'est bon par
que t'a aidé quand même l'amour dans le
Pr je ser pas aujourd'hui mais là je 100
€ JeanMichel je suis tellement cont pour
toi merci c'est gentil et donc là ça
c'est fini pourquoi il y a 3 mois on a
décidé parce que cétait après voilà n
regarde tous les deux
ord accord pas ouf quoi voilà c'est tu
rest combien de temps avec je suis resté
3 semaines oh ça
va rigz mais
raison Rais pas une
histoire
avantou je suis resté presque 2 ans avec
ah ou dis-moi toi tu
esment on be je suis comme tout le monde
pr monde qui tu étais avec une meuf
pendant 2 ans ouais presque 2 ans ouais
et tu l'as connu comment je l'ai connu
euh je l'ai connu sur les réseaux sur
facebook donc VO et alors vous êtes
resté de an donc c'était une bellene his
et pourquoi c'est fini parce que c'est
pareil on accord décié un accord on a
décidé par un accord un accord mais tu
signes des accords non non parce qu'en
fait moi j'ai acheté une maison j'avais
acheté une maison à avant et elle
voulait pas déménager non donc euh moi
je voulais à ma propre maison doncou
mais si pas déménager
oui Kell est-ce que les femmes que tu
Péchaud depuis l'émission que tu as fait
à l'époque c'est des femmes qui t'ont vu
et qui sont un petit peu fan de toi ou
ce sont des dames qui savent pas qui tu
es et les 3/4 c'est les femmes que qui
m'ont vu après les tr/ il y en a
combien ça veut dire que toi tu as fait
l'émission quelle année toi 2011 ça veut
dire que en 11 ans apparemment tu as
tuas tuas roué ta bossse bah je me
plains pasas tu as P combien de meufs
depuis de je sais pas je pr
pr rigol sans rigoler une
[Applaudissements]
vingtaine le gars il est rentré dans
l'amour et dans le Pr cétait c'était
Monseigneur Monseigneur lu il est sorti
[Applaudissements]
chez un truc
deou mais par parents depuis depuis
l'émission C'est beau oh ça t'a bien
aidé l'émission comment tuas bien aidé
l'mission ah ouioui l'émission JE reg
[Applaudissements]
pas j'ai passé des bons moments tout ça
donc Monne oui a est-ce qu'il y a une
meuf qui a eu un coup de cœur et ça
c'est
fini oui j'ai j'ai une fille oui que
j'ai un coup de cœur que j'ai toujours
aujourd'hui c'est Nathalie laamétis elle
est toujours dans mon cœur et tou toute
ma vie dans mon cœur on en est où j'ai
plus de nouvelle attention pas de
nouvelle bonne nouvell en pas de
nouvelle pendant très longtemps très
mauvaise nouvelle
va le voir ce soir
peutêtreie tu saiselle est déclaration
ah je sais pasux faire une déclaration
pe ça peut passer non
non t' juste une question si a toujours
la chè love love touour la chvre love
love un débutie est-ce que tu as
toujours la chèvre love love question de
Jean hier ce qui a été très commenté sur
les réseaux c'est l'attitude d'Olivier
l'éleveur de nouvelle aquitain qui
clairement semble n'avoir rien à
de sa prétendante
Corine elle a tellement elle ça l'a
tellement choqué qu'elle n'arrive même
plus à trouver les
motse je mettre un je grosse
suite
le café il est fait si tu veux oui ouii
attends je suis en train de passer un
coup de file je te l'ai pas servi pour
que tu les Choues allô allô oui oui allô
allô je vais aller me changer après
Olivier parce que je vais avoir tris
habill comme çair le temps et
ohais au revoir Corine bon retour
mercici et merci de ta hospitalisation
hospitalisation halité hospitalité merci
et ben bon
retour heure hier soir qu'est-ce que tu
en penses à tuaimes pas ça tuaimes pas
l'attitude du gars ah si j'aime bien ah
ou après la façon de dire non mais bon
après bouge à fin tu t'enas les steaks
quoi non je m'as pas les steaks mais bon
dire oui c'est pas beau il s'intéresse
pas du tout à elle il est en train de
téléphoner parce qu'il a une chè qui a
été égorgée peut-être par un loup c'est
très important mais c'est très important
mais elle elle est là il est
complètement indifférent donc au bout
d'un moment elle dit je ne compte pas je
ne suis pas là je m'en vais voilà il il
a per surt une femme adorable la veille
elle lui avait organisé la veille elle
lui avait organisé une soirée au karaoké
il a été odieux j'aime pas le karaoké il
a fait aucun effort elle elle voilà elle
elle a pris elle a quand même essayé de
de le calmer d'être sympa et le matin
horri non mais c'est un gouj fini alors
pas être sympa il est bruit de
décoffrage nature s est vraiment comme
ça il va pas forcer sa
nature les amis làhaut on n pas chez vos
mè on peut on peut pas quand même le
forcer à aimer cette
cette et après il y a des gens qui sont
qui ne se forcent pas à aimer il est
peut-être aussi timide et gêné et mal à
l'aise pour elle de lui dire bah écoute
tu ne m'intéresse pas donc parfois les
gens manquent un peu d'honnêteté mais
par gentillesse donc c'est c'est aussi
compliqué on pas c'est sympa mais tu as
pas dû voir l'émission il c'est un Gou
fini c'est
horrible tu pas de respect mais non mais
fait
t mais oh c'est pas parce que tu es un
petit peu bien habillé que tu
dois c'est bon nous aussi on a des
habilles désolé tiens
oui mais je pense à un truc j'ai Enis
tes célibes B oui oh c'est
[Applaudissements]
vra
SEM meuf pour toi bien sûr Daniel est
célibataire moi aussi mais bon quoi toi
aussi B voilà pour un der toute amitié
avec
[Musique]
plaisir en langage agriculteur c'est
Arato je vous le confirme je conais unu
langage agriculteur c'est et je dis mais
çauraitêre t style je sais pas mais on
aurait puuser on aurait pu creuser
unendre à se
connaîre dire est-ce que tu vas aller
dîner avec Daniel oui avec grand plaisir
et tu penses que voilà tu fais
con
transe faut laisser les choses autant
peut-être que bientôt il y aura grand
papa dans
grandmaman
on va pas se
mentir non mais c'est vrai on va pas se
mentir alors il y en a une autre qui
part et qui sa pas son choix c'est
Elodie la prétendante de Joris
l'agriculteur préfère Karine et on sent
qu'Elodie elle a pas du tout envie que
ça marche pour sa concurrence elle veut
leur mettre des bâton dans les roues
regardez effectivement j'ai un ressenti
que voilà vous devenez vous devenez de
plus en plus complice tu te dois vivre
ici sais entre le dire et le faire pere
qu'au début tu aurais du mal un peu à
t'abitué à la campagne ça te ferait rien
d'être aussi loin de tes parents moi
j'espère pour toi que Karine va
s'intégrer ou parce que je pense que le
changement le changement de vie là et
elle a pas le permis aussi hein tu vas
devoir la
voyager je suis très contente de vous
avoir rencontré tous les deux autant
l'un que l'autre pareil franchement je
vous apprécie beaucoup et franchement je
croise les doigts pour
vous on sent que c'est pas ouf
les boules euh jeanis toi tu es tu en
est tu es sur un bail ou pas en ce
moment un bail de meuf ou pas du tout
pas du tout pas du tout là ça va très
bien comme ça non j'ai pas mal dédicace
j'ai pas mal de marché de Noël donc je
suis pris avec mes livres donc pour le
moment ouais pour l'instant après je
peux ça Marie de rencontrer des gens
voilà dans les salons de lives dans les
marchés de Noël bah pour l'instant avant
Noël tu feras rien quoi je sais
pasenir pass avec les boules au pied du
sapin
ouis je te dis voilà je te demande moiis
voilà alors hier céit un épisode
particulièrement émouvant parce que
c'était la fin de l'aventure pour pas
mal de prétendantes et de prétendants
qui nauront pas vu long feu l'aventure
on leur rend homage ce soir big up à
tous clotild firm Elodie Corine es sont
pas
Mortin clotild le suspense sera de
courte durée point de vue feeling
sensation ben c'est vrai que j'ai eu
moins de moins d'approche avec toi comis
écoutez profitez bien je vous fais des
gros bisous
bisous allez ça roule ouais nickel allez
bisous bisous prenez soin de vous
ciao j'ai beaucoup réfléchi et je t'aime
beaucoup franchement je mais j'ai pas je
ressens rien non mais c'est enfin pour
moi malheureusement l'aventure
s'arrête mais par contre si tu veux bien
qu'on reste en contact même moi je
t'aime
bien
e c'est dur hein de de faire son choix
céit dur dans l'aventure c'est un câble
ouais c'est vrai que c'est dur faut faut
bien choisir la bonne personne ah c'est
pas évident et alors ttoi pour l'instant
on reste comme ça tu as pas envie de
statuo après si voilà si je tuhabites où
là en ce moment j je suis j'habite à
côté saintementouren enfin à côté de
tour à Tavant d'accord tu restes sur
Paname ce soir ce soir je reste à Paris
bah dîner alors on va dîner avec
ou pasîn avec Daniel bah pourquoi pas tu
dis avec qui ce soir je suis tout seul
oh je dire quand le destin frappe à
ta il est où Jean Didier que je tire la
carte là
pour Mme pas je l' même pas vu partir
celci
il son tar c'est
voltilisé on l'embrasse on
l'bre merci d'avoir été là est-ce que tu
as un autre truc un dernier truc à nous
dire sur l'amour est dans le Pr donc tu
kiffes plus non je regarde plus je vous
dire la vérité je regarde plus ça fait 4
ans que je regarde plus vraiment ah
ouais tu as fait un Roger quoi voilà
j'ai je trouve que c'est plus comme
avant mais c'est quoi qui à à part fut
voir des grosses feres il font voir que
les agriculteurs il gagnent de l'argent
donc ça les autres agriculteurs ils
disent quoi bah après moi je suis ils
sont comme moi il y en a certains qui
regardent il yr qui regardent plus dis
ils disent comme toi souvent oui donc
bon écoute aujourd'hui tu es heureux
aujourd'hui je suis heureux donc salarié
là aujourd'hui je suis salarié pu j'ai
créé ma propre maison édition donc ouais
salarié tu as créé ta propre maison
d'édition les animaux ne mone pas il ne
juge pas tuas un très beau livre avec
des B photos a un très beau
chevreuil en
couverture c'est beau c'est c'est un
loup ça oui c'est pas un loup c'est un
chien on dirait un
Lou compru
[Applaudissements]
franchement tu chipotes tu chipotes je
chipotes pas pour moi c'est un loup et
un homme heureux Jean-Michel si tu
racontes quoi dans dans ça par tu as
l'air pas heureux de ouf là tu tu l'air
heureux de ouf en fait je raconte ma vie
que j'ai écrit avec Alexis ch ouais donc
on l' écrit ensemble et je raconte ma
vie de de ma naissance à aujourd'hui
donc c'est un très beau livre on Leit
quand même min même si tu regardes plus
l'amour est dans le prê a changé ta vie
bah oui ah oui c'est clair oui
franchement je regrette pas puis Karine
elle est vraiment adorable donc je
l'adore voilà et c'est toujours tu es
toujours un peu sur
Nathalie Nathalie c'est qui comment elle
s'appelle ch Nathalie la chèvre love
love la chèvre Natalie ou toujours sur
elle non pu
aujourd'hui une autre natthalie que j'ai
connu une métisce
Natalie dis-moi en
fait allez
frérot un lou en fait c'est un jour une
meuf c'est un loup le gars c'est vrai
c'est donc donc là c'est un autre bail
encore bon très bien on espère que ça va
se faire elle a quelqu'un ou pas ah j'ai
plus de nouvelle non plus
alors écoute en tout cas on te souhaite
beaucoup de bonheur mer beaucoupû tu
sais que tu vas bon dîner ce soir soir
tu vasir tu vas ou non mais vraiment
est-ce que c'est vous qui payez
le est-ce que c'est vous qui payz
à tout de
suite